yannick vaugrenard a repris son bâton de
pèlerin et attaquer une série de
réunions pour convaincre les quelques
deux mille neuf cent grands électeurs de
loire atlantique
et si l'étiquette socialiste ne fait pas
forcément rêver
le sénateur sortant accompagné de sa
colistière michel meunier met en avant
le travail accompli durant les six
années passées
j'étais important du projet de loi y en
en artisanat commerce et très petites
entreprises au moment où vous en
souvenez probablement il y avait des
problèmes avec les auto entrepreneurs
mais face à lui le sénateur en campagne
rencontre surtout beaucoup d'inquiétudes
et d'interrogations
les contrats aidés sont en train d'être
supprimés et ça a été fait très
rapidement mais extrêmement concret à la
rentrée des classes notre part ils sont
inquiets parce que la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation ils n'ont pas la
certitude qu'elle sera compensée
entièrement par les haines de l'état
donc s'imposer difficulté voilà les dons
qui sont préoccupés nous relaierons ses
occupations
même constat pour le sénateur ronan
dantec
la grogne monte massivement dans les
territoires moi je groupe
l'initiative concernant l'éducation
nationale l'initiative aux maires des
communes soit on fait quinze jours sont
au fait qu'un tueur n ya même pas une
bilan fait de cette réforme dans cette
ville en est pour charmer les élus les
étiquettes politiques ne font plus
recette
avec sa liste vivre les territoires
l'écologiste l'a bien compris il faut
aussi des parlementaires au sénat des
sénateurs qui ne soit pas totalement
dans les jeux politiques nationaux et
dans les appareils politiques nationaux
et train des éléments fou très fort
comporte c'est quand même de dire que le
sénateur ou les sénateurs parce qu'on
espère peut-être avoir deux élus qui
seront élus à partir de notre démarche
seront mandatées aussi ensuite sur les
grandes lois non pas par un appareil
politique nationale mais par les élus du
territoire convaincre discuter échanger
rassurer c'est le quotidien d'un
sénateur en campagne le sénateur udi
joël guerriau n'y échappe pas il
sillonne le département à la rencontre
des élus locaux depuis des mois de
travaux énormes lâchez-vous là c'est
impressionnant ce qu'est en train de se
fermer en octobre 2010 des dizaines
d'entretiens qui ont nourri le candidat
et son programme
moi j'ai collecté tout ce que les gens
ressentent est donc le programme il
porte sur 3 2 3 de même qu'ils sont liés
finalement à ceux ressentis des élus et
en particulier à ce qu'ils étaient
redondantes ce qui se disait le plus ce
sur quoi les gens revenaient le plus
souvent nous on la semaine prochain la
foire de béré à châteaubriant je pense
qu'elle a un salon deux collègues à spa
ce moment là encore on y sera dans cette
campagne il fait figure de petit nouveau
même s'il est loin d'être novice en
politique
christophe priou a été investie
tardivement par les républicains au
détriment du sénateur sortant andré
trillard cet ancien maire du croisic et
de guérande souhaite améliorer le statut
de l'élu
sur les 600 milles presque 600 milles
locaux 9 sur 10 sont bénévoles
si demain on limitait pourquoi pas le
nombre de mandats trois mandats dans le
même poste quelqu'un qui par exemple
mais même à temps partiel sa carrière
professionnelle en parenthèse entre 30
ans et 48 ans il doit pouvoir
bénéficiez d'une formation continue d'un
retour à l'emploi est quelque chose qui
serait sans doute novateur qui existe
dans notre pays une valeur et une
validation des acquis d'expérience la
carte de la nouveauté
bernard morilleau voulait lui aussi la
mettre en avant au nom de la majorité
présidentielle ancien agriculteur maire
de sainte pazanne
il incarnait le renouvellement politique
souhaitée par la république en marche
investi par le parti en juillet reçu au
sénat il ya quelques jours par françois
patriat chef de file de la macro ni
bernard moriau a finalement appris le
week-end dernier sa des investitures au
profit d'une élue guérandaise des volte
face qui illustre parfaitement le
malaise au sein de la république en
marche
à trois semaines des élections
sénatoriales